Musik
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr da seid zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Wen ihr da gerade hört, das bin ich, Florentin Will, aber mir gegenüber sitzt der eigentliche Star der Folge, Stefan Thiese. Stefan Thiese, ich dachte immer, das Intro, das eigentliche Star der Folge, das kam nämlich heute von, den Namen hast du wie immer, Leonard kam dabei, der uns dieses exklusierte Mittelalter-Intro geschickt hat. Er schrieb dabei, freut euch auf die Mittelalter-Vibes, meinst du das Banjo? Meinst du das Mittelalter-Instrument Banjo?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das, also ich habe ja viele alte Höhlenmalerei und Wandmalereien in Burgen gesehen, das Banjo ist mir noch nicht untergekommen.
Ne, dafür so eine geile E-Gitarre, habe ich noch häufig gesehen.
So eine geile Spitze mit so zwei, eine Double-Neck-Gitarre, wo schön die Kings und Queens draufgespielt haben.
Im Grunde eigentlich haben ja die Griechen mit ihrer doppelten Nasenflöte schon die Grundsteine gesetzt für Kiss, für diese ganzen Bands, die wir lieben und verehren. Nenn mir drei Bands, die du liebst und verehrst. Leonard Scannard, The Shins, The Smiths und Richie Bands. Und ich glaube, alle stehen ja in Tradition dieser Nasenflöte, die ja tatsächlich zwei Flöten ist, die in einer V-Form zusammengepattext wurden, nehme ich mal an damals. Und dann kommt so ein Klinkekabel raus, direkt in den Marshall-Verstärker, Marshallus. Weil die sich wahrscheinlich dachten, ich habe zwei Nasendöcher, ich habe zwei Hände, da kriegen wir doch was hin. Oder das liegt doch nahe. Lassen Sie uns mal unseren Körper angucken, ob wir da nicht was draus machen können. Ob da nicht mehr Potential drin liegt als nur Pfeifen. Glaubst du, was warst du zuerst da? Der Ohrwurm, also dass man etwas gepfiffen hat oder wirklich Musik? Ach so, du meinst schon die Steinzeitmenschen so. Ja, alle so, Ja, alle so. Was ist das? Was ist das nochmal? Ach ja, wir haben keinen Song. Es gibt keinen Song bislang. Was ist das nochmal? Ach ja, es gibt, wir haben Musik noch nicht erfunden. Ach ja, stimmt. Ich vergesse das immer wieder. Ich denke immer, irgendwo erkenne ich das. Nee, wir haben noch keine Musik. Wir haben nicht mal ein Wort dafür. Was war das nochmal? Das kenne ich. Aber viele haben die auch nicht gemacht in ihrer Freizeit, die Steinzeit, Menschen. Die hatten ja schon Grundzüge, Höhle, Feuer, Malerei, aber die hatten kein Rummikub, kein Uno, viel Flaschendrehen, Wahrheit oder Pflicht, glaube ich, war da angesagt am Lagerfeuer. Das war so ein bisschen das Highlight, das rockene Highlight. Wahrheit oder Pflicht und Flaschendrehen ist beides so fucking... Wahrheit oder Pflicht, trau dich aus der Höhle. Wenn es das nicht gäbe, glaube ich, hätte ich bis heute keine sexuelle Erfahrung gemacht. Ich glaube, Wahrheit oder Pflicht und Flaschendrehen hilft der Teenagerwelt da draußen, über die erste Hemmschwelle zu treten. Das Ding ist ja, ich habe immer Wahrheit genommen, weil ich habe nichts zu verbergen, ich habe nichts zu erzählen. Deswegen kann ich eigentlich immer Wahrheit nehmen. Aber eigentlich ist man feige, wenn man immer nur Wahrheit nimmt. Man muss Pflicht nehmen, klar, vor allem wenn dein Schulcrush auch im Kreis sitzt und sie dich anguckt die ganze Zeit und mit ihren Härchen Haaren spielt und die so langsam einkringelt. Ich habe sehr konkrete Vorstellungen vor dem Bad und der Pflicht haben. Mittelalter, ganz ehrlich, was haben die für Musik gemacht? Haben die das festgehalten mit Noten, haben die das auf ihren Wandteppichen zumindest mal ordnungsgemäß festgehalten, dass wir nachvollziehen können, ob die schon Bands hatten. Ja, die hatten doch Bands. Die hatten doch eine Gruppe bestimmt aus Gitarren und Lauten und Leiern. Ich glaube schon, ich glaube, das wurde auch festgehalten, aber man hat halt nicht alles übertragen. Ich glaube, so die richtigen Banger, die richtigen Hits sind verloren gegangen und nur so ein paar Randnotizen sind übrig geblieben. So wie wenn heute irgendwie von unserer Zivilisation nur Friday, Friday übrig bleiben würde. Und dann sagen, ah, das ist die Melodie, das ist die Tonstruktur, Konterpunkt natürlich viel. Thank God it's Friday. Thank God it's Friday. Das war anscheinend für den wichtig. Aber da ist er ganz wichtig. Aber jetzt gibt es ja immer wieder so dieses Punkt, dass Popstars ja von der Klassik klauen, jetzt mit diesem neuen Song von Bella Porch, diese TikTok-Inzender. Bella Porch, Bella Porch, Bella Porch, Bella Porch, ne dieses Nenenenenenenenenenenene, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, was einfach ein Mozart-Lied ist, eins zu eins, eins zu eins Mozart. Und Mozart hat auch direkt gesagt, so nicht der dreiviertel Grammys-Gewinner. Ich meine, Mozart ist ja immer noch einigermaßen cool. Ich glaube, wenn du so einen Popstar einen neuen Track rausbringst, dann stellst du dich heraus, du hast von Rudolfus dem Grauen aus dem 13. Jahrhundert. Dem Barbaren. Von Rudolfus dem Hänger, dem Pfähler, geklaut. Wobei aber auch die einschlägigen Musikmagazine sich schwer tun, da eine schmissige Überschrift draus zu machen, der war Sagen von dem Mensch Rudolfus von Kopenhagen, er hat jetzt tatsächlich Easy Freezy Peace, der neue Super-Shooting-Star aus Kanada, Summer Breezy, der Song, hat mit seinem neuen Track Don't Fuck Me Up leider von Rudolfus von Kopenhagen geklaut. Von dem man glaubt, er wäre Werwolf gewesen, was auch nicht so schlecht ist. Weiß man bis heute nicht tatsächlich. Man geht davon aus. Er hat leider nie auf den Brief geantwortet, in dem die Frage formuliert war. Ja, außer mit diesem Blutspritzer und diesem Tatzenabdruck, aber man konnte bis heute nicht genau zuordnen, was es genau bedeuten soll. Hast du das Gefühl, ich habe ein sehr konkretes Problem? Immer wieder höre ich zum ersten Mal einen Song im Radio zum Beispiel, der wird als der neue Song vorgestellt, von meinetwegen Lady Gaga, von irgendwelchen grossen Popstars. Und allein der Name und halt die Produktion und halt auch das Timing zum Sommer hin suggeriert halt, okay, das wird ein Megahit. Und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich kenne den schon. Aber auch wenn sie sagen, hier zum ersten Mal eine Premiere im Radio bei uns, du spielst mir zum ersten Mal den Song, den neuen Song von Kescher, viel Spaß. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kenne diesen Song, ich komme nicht entweder aus dieser Dimension oder aus der Zukunft, aber ich kenne diesen Song, ich kann den quasi mitsingen, weil es wieder funktioniert funktioniert, das habe ich manchmal. Liegt das ein bisschen an der Popmusik, wie die mittlerweile aufgebaut ist? Dein Problem ist halt, du hast dich halt intensiv mit mittelalterlicher Klostermusik beschäftigt und wie gesagt alle Tracks, Rodolfus von Kopenhagen haut einen Banger nach dem anderen aus und du kennst die halt schon im Original. Ich kenne die im Original. Deswegen kannst du die mitpfeifen, wie damals. Oder bin ich 800 Jahre alt? Vielleicht bist du ein Vampir. Ja. Vielleicht bist du ein Vampir, aber du verlierst immer dein Gedächtnis, wenn du jemanden beißt. Hm. Oder gebissen wirst. Nee. Du verlierst ... Aber ich bin die Autoren für Twilight-Tide 5. Du verlierst ein Bein. Nee, nee, du verlierst ... Du musst ja, um zu überleben, musst du Leute beißen. Das frage ich mich auch mal, warum sind die so jung, die Vampire, warum sehen die so jung aus? Bis mir die Idee kam, die bleiben immer so alt, wie sie in dem Alter waren, als sie gebissen wurden. Die frieren in ihrem Alter ein. So, das ist ja schon ein Problem, weil ich bin ja gealtert schon in meinem Leben. Du kennst mich ja auch schon, da war ich noch ganz klein. Wer weiss, wenn du vor zwei Jahren gebissen worden wärdest, hätte man das nicht gesehen.
Wie lange muss man altern, bis man merkt, Alter, du alterst nicht mehr?
Gute Frage.
Schwierig. Ich glaube, hat sich man natürlich mit der mittelalterlichen Vampirforschung auch intensiv gefragt.
Weil da wachsen ja noch die Haare eigentlich und so alles und Fingernägel.
Fingernägel und die Nase wächst weiter. Das ist ein großes Problem.
Man altert halt nur nicht mehr. Aber ich glaube, Vampire können sich Frisuren technisch neu orientieren. Die sind nicht festgelegt auf einen Blick. Ich glaube, viele Sachen wachsen einfach weiter im Alter, wegen der Gravitation. Die Fingernägel wachsen wegen der Gravitation? Das heißt, wenn du die Hände nach oben streckst, dann wachsen sie wieder rein, werden sie kürzer.
Nee, die werden langsamer wachsen.
Ach so, dann müssen sie ankämpfen gegen die Gravitation.
Ich dachte schon, anstatt die Fingernägel zu schneiden, kannst du einfach die Hand nach oben nehmen und dann gehen die wieder zurück, werden die wieder reingedrückt. Werden einigermaßen wieder reingedrückt, ja. Wie tief gehen die in den Finger rein? Gehen die bis zum Finger ganz runter? Vor allem, meine Haare wachsen so schnell, da wollte ich euch mal fragen da draußen, die Schwammintelligenz. Meine Fingernägel, meine Haare, mein Barthaare, alles wächst so dramatisch schnell. Heißt das, ich habe einen schnellen und langsamen Stoffwechsel, wahrscheinlich schnell, ne? Keine Ahnung. Hat das überhaupt was mit Stoffwechsel zu tun? Ist das Metabolismus, nennt man das so? Dass du eine Art von Superheld bist, die halt die Superkraft mehr so auf viele verschiedene Dinge aufgeteilt hast.
Weil wenn du jetzt sagst, ich kann meine Fingernägel innerhalb kürzester Zeit ganz lang machen, so wie Wolverine, cool. Wer die lange Haare ganz lang machen kann, cool. Wie die von Incredibles. Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Die kann auch ihre Haare lang machen, glaube ich. Ich kenne das nicht. Egal, aber du hast, glaube ich, die Fähigkeiten halt aufgeteilt.
Du kannst ein bisschen Fingernagel, bisschen Länge, bisschen Bart, bisschen Schach, bisschen Körpergröße, aber nichts richtig. Nichts richtig. Ich glaube, du kannst auch so ein paar Millimeter über den Boden fliegen, aber es fällt halt selten auf. Sind wir nicht alle Superhelden, die ihre Kräfte eher nur einigermaßen gleichmäßig aufgeteilt haben, die ein bisschen
zu wenig risikofreundlich an der Skillbar
am Anfang unseres Startbildschirms waren.
Wir dachten alle, wir haben so viele
Punkte, wir können Superhelden, wir können alles auf Fliegen machen.
Am Ende machen wir sehr wenig auf Fliegen.
Den Fehler macht man immer. Weil man merkt, man braucht andere
Sachen, Social Skills. Man will einmal probieren,
aber eigentlich sollte man beim Buffet schon
an den Shrimps stehenbleiben und sich davon einfach drei
Teller voll machen. So.
Was kommt noch besser als Shrimps?
Mehr All-in gehen, mehr auf eine Sache skillen, Spezialisten sein. Schreib das mal auf.
Nee, nee, ich wollte gerade zu unserer Hausaufgabe kommen.
Ich habe keine Erinnerung an unsere Hausaufgabe. Du zeigst auf mich, ich soll dich anmoderieren, ich habe keine Erinnerung an die letzte Folge.
Es könnte die erste Folge sein, basically.
Und hier ist unsere Podcast-Ufo-Hausaufgabe.
Aber, aber, aber, aber, ich weiß nicht. Gebt mir einen Hinweis? Wir haben letzte Woche unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer dazu aufgerufen, mal all inzugehen. Ja, mal all inzugehen. Mal zu sagen, ja, ich lerne mal was, egal ob das nützlich ist oder nicht. Ich lerne mal irgendwas. Man ist ja immer so eingespannt in Effizienz, Ökonomie, man muss wichtige Dinge lernen, man muss meditieren, hundert Instagram-Posts sagen ein, schöpft dein Potential aus, aber nicht konkret was. Mal in was reinzudicken. Ja, mal reinzugraben einfach, immer was reinzugraben. Und da... Ganz kurz, du musst ganz kurz in das Programm gucken, ob wir noch aufnehmen, weil du gerade an alle Kabel gerüttelt hast. Alles gut, alles gut. Das Projekt hängt an einem seidenen Kabel. Und da hat sich Luca gemeldet, denn Luca hat gesagt, ich gehe all in. Ich will in einem Disney-Film, in einem Disney-Pixar-Film, ich will den Namen des Films geben, ich will die Hauptfigur spielen. Und er hat es geschafft. Letzte Woche kam er raus. Vielleicht ist es eine Verfilmung von Lucas Leben, wir wissen es nicht, er hat hier nur einen kleinen Ausschnitt geteilt.
Und Luca hat gesagt, er geht all in, und zwar hat er geschrieben, moin, ich habe ohne Grund Stenografie gelernt, hat lange gedauert und es spart mir keine Zeit. Ist das ein Gag, weil du ihm dann noch Zeit spart. Weiß ich nicht, ich glaube schon. Doch es ist ein klassischer One-Liner, ein Einliner. Nee, glaube ich nicht unbedingt, weil es also ich glaube, der kann es einfach so lernen Und dann spart er nicht wirklich Zeit, weil du wahrscheinlich auch selten irgendwas mitschreibst. Die Idee von Genografie ist, dass man Zeit spart. Ja, aber wenn du es nicht oft nutzt und nicht viel Sachen aufschreibst. Wenn du weder Zeit in Gerichtssälen verbringst. Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Gag ist, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde es aber gut, dass Luca einfach gesagt hat, ich lerne Genografie, ich lerne mal was, ich haue mal was raus. Und man weiß ja nie, was man es nutzen kann. Finde ich sowieso immer die spannendsten in diesen Gerichtsdramen sind diese Gerichtsdramendamen, die da an diesem kleinen Stuhl sitzen und in dieser kleinen Schreibmaschine dann immer so, aber die hauen ja nicht so auf die Tasten, sondern eher die. Die wollen ja auch nicht den Flow unterbrechen, der Schau. Ja, das ist so, als würden die da reinmassieren in dieses Schreibgerät, in diese merkwürdige Alien-Sprache, die nur sie verstehen. Und die sind auch so ein bisschen in Trance, ne? Ja. Die sind ja, die stalten sich ja nicht dazwischen als Mensch. Also die nehmen die Worte auf und geben sie direkt weiter in ihre Hände. Genau, die sind Medium. Die sind einfach nur ein Medium, die sind nicht dazwischen geschaltet. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die nebenbei über was anderes nachdenken können. So, heute Abend eine Folge Fargo gucken, kann ja nicht ein Gedankenprozess sein. Ja, stimmt schon. Aber die erinnern mich irgendwie immer an Mos Eisley, Taverne, da gibt es doch auch diese kleine Alien-Orgel. Taverne? Jeder kennt die Tavernenband. Ich liebe die Tavernenband. Da gibt es doch auch diese kleine Alien-Orgel. Jeder kennt die Tavernen-Band. Ich liebe die Tavernen-Band. Da gibt es auch diese kleine Alien-Orgel, wo dieser blaue Elefant dran sitzt. Du bist gar nicht in Mos Eisley. Du bist in Jabba's Palast. Nee, ich bin in Mos Eisley. Da ist nicht der blaue Elefant. Der blaue Elefant ist in Jabba's Palast. Ja, leg dich ruhig mit mir an. Ja, kann das sein? Ja, das kann schon sein. I have the high ground. Ist gerade ein Heimspiel für mich. Da gab es auch Musik? Ja, ja, okay. Da gab es doch die Max-Rebo-Band. Nein, der war in Mos Eisley. Aber vielleicht hast du recht. Vielleicht hast du recht. Vielleicht habe ich recht. Aber weißt du, was ich meine? Diese Orgel hat was von einem Stenografieapparat, weil die auch so einfach so wabbelig ist, so einfach reinwabbeln. Die Tasten geben nicht nach so richtig und wenn dann so schwammig und man denkt, das kann kein Kerlinstrument sein. Auch hier, irgendein Mensch sass den ganzen Tag in einem blauen Elefantenkostüm und hat auf einer Alien-Orgel willkürlich rumgedrückt. Ja. Willkürlich rumgedrückt, links, rechts, links, rechts, oben, unten, einfach drück, drück, drück, drück, drück.
Nur zusehen, dass man nicht so oft rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts macht, sondern dass man auch mal abwechselt ein bisschen. Einfach den ganzen Tag, Stunde um Stunde, Take um Take um Take und bitte, hat ja auch kein Geräusch gemacht, sondern einfach nur drückt der einfach rum. So ein bisschen klackern, so Plastik auf Plastik. Das war der Job. Der geht abends nach Hause und sagt, ich war heute ein blauer Elefant, der willkürlich auf Tasten gedrückt hat. Aber dann kam Luke rein und so ein Lichtschweig, das war cool. Ja, ich habe ihn leider nicht gesehen, weil mein blauen Elefantenkostüm. Ich leider weder höre, was gesagt wird, deswegen höre ich auch Action nicht, deswegen muss ich durchgehend drücken, auch wenn die in Mittagspause sind, spiele ich immer noch in meiner Alien-Orgel. Und, ähm, sind wir mal ehrlich, Alien-Orgel ist nicht so kreativ und blauer Elefant, ich meine, wir haben schon blaue Milch, machen wir jetzt einfach alles, was normal ist, in blau und na, von mir aus, die Gedanken macht man sich dann. Okay, also ich habe immer noch nicht ganz genau verstanden, was unsere Hausaufgabe von letzter Woche war. Die Hausaufgabe war, die Leute sollen mal all in gehen, einfach mal was machen, nicht immer denken, wohin führt mich das, was sind die Konsequenzen, sondern einfach mal machen. Und Luca war der einzige, der uns geschrieben hat, ansonsten nichts. Niemand hat was gemacht, ich finde die Idee aber gut, einfach mal konkrete Projekte zu machen, weil, wie gesagt, die Leute, es ist zu zerrüttet, lebe deinen Traum, schöpfe dein Potenzial aus, aber was? Ich finde, die Leute sollten sagen, lern Drachensteigen. Einfach direkt Drachensteigen, versuchen, looping. Weißt du, was das Problem ist? Leute wie du. Leute wie du, die dann diesen Leuten immer wieder, wenn ich sage, ich habe eine neue Phase, ich habe jetzt mit Motorboot fahren angefangen. Motorboot? Nein, aber ich habe auch einen Motorbootschein gemacht in der Zwischenzeit. Aber wenn ich dann sowas sage, dann kommt immer von dir erstmal so ein ... Ne? Und das ist das Problem! Ja, weil du eben nicht all in gehst. Ist eine rote Flagge. Nein, du checkst dein Leben davon. Nein, du checkst dein Leben davon. Ich gehe immer kurz all in. Nein, du nimmst die Hand und checkst durch bis zum River und dann legst du sie ab. Du gehst eben nicht all in, das ist nämlich dein Problem.
Nein, doch, ich gehe all in, aber an zu vielen Tischen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, dreh jetzt nicht den Tisch um, dreh jetzt nicht den Pokertisch um, mach jetzt keinen Tag. Ich habe auf allen Tischen ein bisschen Geld, wenig Geld, an allen Tischen zu wenig Geld. Du checkst die Hände durch und foldest dann und gewinnst mal einen kleinen Pot, aber dadurch wird man nicht reich. Nee, für unten. Da muss ich nicht all in.
Sorry, aber da muss ich...
Ich kenne mich auch ein bisschen aus im Poker,
und ich glaube, die Metapher funktioniert richtig gut. Ich finde nicht, weil ich checke nicht durch, weil ich mache zumindest was. Ja, du gehst die Hand und checkst dann durch. In der Metapher spielst du nicht mal am Tisch, du sitzt im anderen Gebäude und spielst was anderes, immer das Gleiche. Nee, nee, nee, du musst dich ja schon dazu entscheiden, Schuhe anzuziehen und ins Bellagio zu gehen, um mal zu gucken, wo sind die Ausgänge, wo sind die Kameras. Das ist schon Teil der Metapher, okay. Ja, du hast schon, naja, es ist schon eine gleichschwebende Aufmerksamkeit und dann setzt du dich an den Tisch und jemand gibt dir die Karten, die nimmst du nur an, du bist passiv. Du siehst in dem Film, oh, da hackt sich jemand rein und du sagst, ich will auch Hacker werden.
Du nimmst die Karten also an, die der Dealer dir gibt.
Und jetzt checkst du nur noch durch.
Das kannst du wirklich gar nicht sagen.
Und jetzt checkst du nur noch durch bis zum River, manchmal gewinnst du einen kleinen Pot, manchmal nicht.
Ich mache ja Dinge dafür, ich dick mich ja rein.
Ja, aber es ist kein All-in, es ist trotzdem noch ein Durchchecken.
Du musst ja auch auf den Tisch klopfen. Bei Kiki-Drink in der Hand mit dem Schirmchen und der Ananas drin stehst du am Rand und machst immer nur, ne, er ist am nächsten Tisch. Nee, ich liege im Bett, ich mach gar nichts. Du bist im Bett. Ich bin im Überwachungsraum, schau dich über die Überwachungskamera an und sag, ja, der macht das nicht richtig. Und er macht selber gar nichts. Aber sichern sie immer den Tresorraum. Ja. Und ich habe einen Hinweis, Minibar. Gummibärchen in der Minibar. Nee, im Englischen ist es nämlich nur Minibar. Ja, ich weiss, das haben wir schon. Wir haben tatsächlich mit dem Übersetzer telefoniert, der das übersetzt hat. Frank Schacht hat diese Szene übersetzt aus dem Englischen, ins Deutsche, und hat Gummibärchen in der Minibar eingebaut. Ich finde gut, dass so Probleme, die hier auftauchen, in anderen Projekten deines Lebens, löst du die, finde ich okay, mach das ruhig.
Aber dann kannst du mich zumindest updaten, dass du die Lösung hast.
Um das zu klären, viele Leute fragen sich, warum Gummibärchen in der Minibar, was genau bedeutet dieser Satz?
Und wir haben extra Frank Schacht angerufen und gefragt, warum haben sie übersetzt, I got two words for you, Minibar.
Warum haben sie das übersetzt in, ich habe einen Tipp für Sie, Gummibärchen in der Minibar. Wo kommen die Gummibärchen her? Und er hat gesagt, er kann sich nicht mehr daran erinnern. Nein, weil ich habe es auch mal recherchiert. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es mal recherchiert und es war einfach, weil es gab gar keine Minibars in Hotels. Genau, ja. Und das gab es lange keine Minibars. Und da gab es dann doch eine, von daher hat er dann dadurch Ted Bennet gesagt, ich habe sehr wohl hier geschlafen bei dir im Hotel. Ja, oder er wollte ihm Tipp geben, weil Rusty ja auch im Hotelbusiness ist, deswegen gibt dir dem Team, I got one word for you, Minibar. Also, Bau Minibars in deine Hotels. Davon sagt er doch, ich habe in ihrem Hotel geschlafen sogar. I got one word for you Minibar. Genau. Ich glaube, das sagt aus. Tipp, man weiss es nicht. Wie gesagt, diese Zeile ist super kryptisch, man weiss nicht genau, worum es geht, und solange Frank Schacht sich nicht erinnert, wissen wir es auch nicht. Die ganze Welt wartet an der Erinnerung an dem Main-Tempel von Frank Schacht der sich nicht erinnern kann, warum er es so übersetzt hat. Wollen wir ihm mal, das wäre vielleicht der nächste Schritt, ihm noch Hypnose schenken, weil es gibt doch... Ja, das fände ich richtig gut. Weil es ist die lustigste Geschichte immer noch, irgendwie so ein jünger Typ hat irgendwie so Millionen mit Bitcoins gemacht und hat das Passwort, er hat drei Versuche, das Passwort richtig einzugeben, danach wird das gelöscht und da sind Millionen drauf und er hat es schon zweimal falsch eingegeben. Und dann hat er sogar so Hypnosen gemacht und sich hypnotisieren lassen, um halt sich das Passwort wieder in den Kopf zu bringen. Und ich finde es fantastisch. Deswegen sollten wir wahrscheinlich zu Frank Schacht fahren und ihm sagen, so, wir schenken dir eine Hypnose, um an dieses Wissen aus einer Vergangenheit zu kommen. Das klappt ja. Das wird auch teilweise mit Zeugen und Augenzeugen gemacht. Ja, ja. Ich finde das eine gute Idee. Wir müssen da halt nur die Mail gut schreiben, weil ich glaube, da ist man erst mal skeptisch, wenn irgendein Podcast kommt und dich hypnotisieren lassen wird. Ich würde absehen von Betreff Hypnose. Betreff, wir stellen sie unter Hypnose. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Betreff ist erstmal sowas wie lose Anfrage.
Ja, ja, ja. Betreff
nichts grosses.
Nee, nee. Nur mal so nebenbei.
Lesen sie erstmal die Mail.
Ja, das ist mal ein guter Betreff.
Finde ich eine gute Idee, aber das finde ich eine gute Idee,
in das Bergwerk von Frank Schacht
einzusteigen und ganz tief
in die Gruben zu gehen, um irgendwo noch dieses Wissen rauszuneolen. Wir können aber einfach Steven Soderberg fragen. Können wir auch machen. Was auf Englisch heißt zumindest. Wir haben ja Steven Soderberg mal beim Penny gesehen. Wir haben ihn mal beim Penny gesehen. Als Verkäufer, merkwürdigerweise. Das weiß ich auch nicht, was das heute, aber vielleicht macht er Research. Aber haltet man die Augen offen, manchmal sieht man solche Leute. Manchmal sieht man, nee, nur Steven Soderberg, tatsächlich. Ich habe noch nicht viele andere Prominente gesehen. Aber Steven Soderberg ist schon ... In Köln ist der unterwegs. In Köln, aber auch in Hamburg in meiner Heimatstadt kam, haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal gesehen. Googelt mal, wie der aussieht, falls ihr nicht wisst, wie Steven Soderberg aussieht, er sieht ein bisschen aus wie Moby. Wie ein Random Guy auch ein bisschen. Ja, wie ein Random Guy Moby. Moby. So, wenn man bei Moby bei GTA dann nochmal auf zufällig klickt, so Moby einstellt und dann nochmal so ein bisschen random mit rein, so ein bisschen nochmal krude. So ungefähr sieht Steven Soderbergh aus. Also haltet die Augen auf.
Nee, das war Antenne Five Diamonds Awards, Antenne Eleven, weiss ich nicht, fällt uns bestimmt was mit A ein.
Aber ja, ich bin trotzdem nach wie vor sehr sauer über dich und deine blöde Metapher, weil dann machst du mir es irgendwie zum Vorwurf, mich so durchzuchecken in meinem Leben und so. Und das mache ich nicht. Dafür gehe ich zu oft. In diese Bootsphase bin ich auch hingegangen. Kurz mal alle Zeit rein investiert, mir die Scheine abgeholt und zack, next Projekt. Next Projekt. Was ist das nächste Projekt? Weiss ich noch nicht. Weiss ich noch nicht. Das ist eigentlich spannend. Man weiss nie, was kommt. Man muss die nächste Staffel angucken, man bleibt dran, das ist ein Cliffhanger. Sport vielleicht mal wieder, das finde ich ganz gut. Ich versuche das immer so einzureden, dass mein nächstes Projekt ist gute Ernährung und mein Körper sagt auch so ja. Ja, mach mal eine Erfindung, mach mal eine Erfindung, weil, wie gesagt, Tietze ist kein schlechter Name für eine Erfindung. Mich nerven Leute, die gute Erfindungen haben, aber komplizierte Namen haben.
Röntgen, Röntgen.
Röntgen zum Beispiel.
Vor allem, war es nicht so, dass Röntgen sogar aktiv dagegen waren, dass die Strahlen Röntgenstrahlen genannt werden? Er war für X-Ray. Er war für X-Ray, X-Strahlen, und die Amerikaner haben gesagt, X-Ray, geil, klingt mega gut. Klingt mega cool. Mega gut, aber die Deutschen haben gesagt, nee, Röntgen. Nee, ich lasse mich heute Röntgen. Röntgen, vor allem das Problem ist halt, ich glaube, die Überlegung von Röntgen war so, und das unterstreiche ich, ich glaube, der war noch ziemlich am Anfang seiner Karriere, als diese Strahlen plötzlich in sein Leben kamen und er diese Strahlen erforscht hat. Und wahrscheinlich dachte er sich, das ist nicht mein Höhepunkt, das ist nicht mein Lebenswerk. Mein Gott, hier mal so ein paar Strahlen. Das ist die Röntgenstrahlen, den kann man diesen Namen geben. Nee, aber wenn du schon, weil du kannst ja nicht Röntgenstrahlen haben und dann noch den Röntgen-Effekt, so, denn du bist ja schon verbrannt. Wenn du irgendwann mal so einen Namen etabliert hast, du musst eigentlich wissen, schaffe ich danach noch einen grösseren Wurf oder kann ich jetzt schon meinen Namen hergeben. So, das ist so das Ding und ich glaube, das ist eine ganz schwierige Situation für viele Wissenschaftler, die sich denken, soll ich jetzt schon irgendwie, das ist das heimliche Manöver. Kommt da noch mehr dahinter? Kommt von dem Erfinder des heimlichen Manövers, geht da noch mehr? Ist das alles, also jemanden von hinten packen und dann kurz nach oben reißen. Ist das mein Lebenswerk? Das ist mein Lebenswerk. Rettet viele Menschen, wird häufig benutzt. Ja, aber vielleicht, finde ich ja noch irgendwie so eine Matte, die man unter Brücken klebt, dass man da irgendwie reinfällt. Sie haben jetzt noch die Möglichkeit, dieses Formular auszufüllen. Wir müssen es jetzt einreichen. Ah, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe da noch so eine Idee, dass... Allein die Vorstellung, dass es dieses Formular gibt, wo man den Namen für die Erfindung eintragen kann, wo gross steht, Name der Erfindung und man hat diese eine Chance, diesen einen Shot. Ja, ich habe noch so eine Idee für so eine lange Stange, mit der man einfach Katzen aus dem Baum rausholen kann, die Heimlichstange. Ah, ich weiß nicht, das Manöver oder die Stange. Aber jetzt denken Sie doch mal, wie viele Menschenleben das rettet. Ja, ich weiss ja, was Sie sagen. Ich verstehe ja, was Sie sagen. Aber wenn ich mich jetzt festlege, wie viele Menschenleben könnten dadurch gefährdet sein, dass sich aufhören, neue Dinge zu erfinden. Okay, ich brauche jetzt eine Antwort. Wollen Sie nicht erst mal einen Keks essen? Ich lasse... Ich habe hier extra Kekse für Sie mitgebracht. Lassen wir noch kurz noch mal Zeit. Nehmen Sie sich mal einen Keks und dann ... Okay. Vielleicht diese Stange. Der ist ja fantastisch, der Keks. Ja, die sind gut, ne? Die sind richtig lecker. Was ist das für ein Keks? Die sind ein bisschen trocken, aber schon lecker. Leibniz-Keks? Naja, ich packe die halt nebenbei so ab und zu. Leibniz. Der berühmte Mathematiker Leibniz. Und Philosoph Leibniz, ja. Reduziert auf Keks. Ja. Da entscheiden Sie sich erstmal, ob Sie das Manöver so nennen wollen, wie sie heissen. Wie das der Mann hinter Ihnen. Was kann ich denn für Sie tun? Ja, hallo! Hi. Sie wollen eine Erfindung benennen, deswegen sind Sie im Erfindungsbenennungsinstitut Raum drei, nehme ich an. Ja, ja. Was haben Sie denn erfunden? Ja, also ich bin Walter Knigge und ich habe die Idee, dass man erst mit dem kleinen Löffel isst und dann mit dem grossen. Sie meinen, dass man sich quasi von außen nach innen ahnt mit dem Besteck. Nicht von oben nach unten oder unten nach oben, das bringt nichts, das ist Quatsch, sondern von außen nach innen. Erstmal, ich finde es toll, dass Sie als Einzige angeklopft haben, bevor Sie den Raum betreten haben. Natürlich. Ich finde es toll, dass Sie draußen gewartet haben. Sie sind der Einzige, der gut angezogen ist, finde ich. Auch gut, dass der untere Knopf auf ist und der obere zu, wie sich das für den Sack umgehebt.
Das muss schon alles sein. Entschuldigung, jetzt bin ich Ihnen kurz ins Wort gefallen.
Nee, gar kein Problem, aber da kann sich ja heimlichen, will ich ein Beispiel vordran nehmen, der beide Knöpfe zugemacht hat.
Kann ich Ihnen Kicks erbieten? Ja, danke, nehme ich gerne an. Oh, die sind aber etwas trocken. Herr Heimlich, Ihr Manöver! Ich überlege gerade. Machen Sie das Heimlich-Manöver! Ich überlege gerade. Machen Sie das Heimlich-Manöver! Ich kann das Heimlich-Manöver nicht. Ich habe es nur erfunden, aber ich kann das nicht. Herr Knigge! Ist tot. Wir müssen die Röntgen. Ja bitte? Hat jemand meinen Namen gesagt? Es ist schwierig, aber ich glaube, in eine ähnliche Richtung geht es auch mit Strassennamen. Ey Leute, wirklich geil, dass ihr euch für schwache Leute einsetzt oder für Bürgerrechte oder irgendwie was baut. Aber halt nicht, wenn ihr irgendwie Knofotzki heisst oder irgendwie Bartolomäus. Können wir kurz ein Was wäre wenn für das Hörschbüro gerade machen? Ich würde gerne, was wäre wenn eine Möglichkeit, in welche Richtung es noch gegangen könnte. Ich muss nur noch darüber lachen, die Kekse habe ich jetzt verstanden, die sind so trocken, weil du wolltest, dass du... Ich biete was an. So, ich dachte, ich war kurz, ah, Herr Tuck ist gekommen, war ich kurz dabei, dann dachte ich, hätte ich die Lösung gehabt, ich finde auch gut, dass du mir so Rätsel entstellst, mit Herrn Leibniz, dass das beides nie on the table war, weil du nur wolltest, dass man sich verschluckt, um möglichst schnell aus diesem Sketch rauszukommen. Ich war kurz davor Herrn Tuck, ihr habt Herrn Tuck verpasst. Aber würdest du Tuck als Keks bezeichnen? Nein, das ist ein klassischer Cracker. Oh, jetzt geht's los. Die Kekskräcker-Debatte, wollen wir die jetzt wirklich nochmal aufmachen? Wollen wir die jetzt hier ausfechten? Die Stuttgarter Kekskräcker-Debatte, die damals mit dem Tod von drei Linguisten und vier Anthropologen ausgegangen ist, wo wir das wirklich noch machen. Wo wir das Todesstrafe belegt ist. Der Stuttgarter Prozesse. Keksprozesse. Nee, wollen wir nicht diskutieren. Das ist unangenehm und da hat auch niemand Spaß dran da draußen. Aber auch so, wenn du Verträge unterzeichnest, ab einem gewissen Punkt muss man ja sich genau überlegen, wo. Weil du kannst jetzt nicht sagen, wir wollen einen grossen Friedensvertrag, können wir nicht in Kyoto unterschreiben. Weil die Stadt ist verbrannt, die Stadt ist weg, kannst du nicht machen. Du kannst auch nicht einen Vertrag in Versailles unterschreiben, du musst dann halt irgendwie in die Provence. Aber du kannst keine Konvention mehr in Genf unterzeichnen. Nee, das geht nicht. Aber du kannst einen Vertrag in Genf unterzeichnen. Oder eine Konvention in Kyoto. Die Kyoto-Konvention. Oder eine Konvention in Versailles. Ja. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch ein guter Ort ist, um Dinge zu unterschreiben, aber warum nicht? Ein bisschen überlaufen, touristisch meine ich jetzt. Ach ja, mein Gott, aber da hast du auch ein paar nette Räume mit Klimaanlage. Ja, und ist doch nett, wenn die Leute hereingucken, da wird was unterzeichnet, das schauen die Leute immer gerne an. Schengen ist, glaube ich, verbrannt. Nee, Schengen kann es ja nicht. Weil Schengen benutzt man mittlerweile auch so einfach, das ist Schengen. So ohne Abkommen, Vertrag, Klausel, Passus. Ja, ja, ja, nee, das ist nichts. Das ist nichts. Nee, kann man nicht mehr benutzen. Unterschreiben ist, finde ich, immer ein geiles Gefühl. Unterschreiben, ich weiß nicht, warum ich glaube, es ist auch mittlerweile komplett nutzlos. Unterschreiben, ich glaube, das bräuchte es nirgendwo mehr, weil mittlerweile kann man auch digital unterschreiben, wo ich teilweise meine Signatur schon vorgeschrieben habe und rein Copy-Paste, wo ich mir denke, das kann jeder andere auch machen. Ich habe von Verwandten von mir, die bereits gestorben sind, die Unterschriften noch in meinem Laptop. Und ich könnte, ich dachte nur so viel, ich könnte beim Finanzamt komische Sachen machen.
Moment mal. Du könntest Geister erzählen, Ghost Tax? Ghost Tax. Ghost Tax, der neue Spielfilm von Stefan Tietze und Steven Soderberg von der Lidl-Kasse? Und wir denken so, krasser Plot, cool. Und das Finanzamt ruft an und sagt, wahrscheinlich haben sie sich einfach vertan mit der digitalen Unterschrift.
Wie viel Steuern müssen Geister zahlen? Gibt es da eine Regelung?
Geister sind steuerfrei, bis zu einem Einkommen von 100.000 im Jahr.
Aber Geister haben in der Regel kein Einkommen.
Ja, so Mozart hat noch Einkommen.
Ja, stimmt, stimmt.
Weil andere Popstars von ihm klauen, als er noch The Mozart hisst. Drop the the. Drop the the. Drop the Amadeus. Haben ihm bestimmt auch viele Leute gesagt, oder? Ist ja entspannend, dieser Moment, wo man sagt, ich bin jetzt, hab jetzt einen Zweitnamen, so, ich bin jetzt Wolfgang Amadeus. Und wo man nicht einfach Wolfgang Amadeus, sondern der ist auch noch dabei. So, da muss ja irgendwann die Entscheidung gekommen sein, ich mach das jetzt. Du bist ja auch nicht Stefan Michael Thietze. Du bist ja nicht SMT. Ich bin SMT. Du bist ST. Wir kennen dich als ST. Du bist FDP. Ich bin nicht FDP. Florentin David Pascal Will oder Pascal David Will, das weiß ich jetzt heute nicht genau, wie die Reihenfolge ist. Ich glaube so, dass es passt mit der Partei FDP. Nee, FPD glaube ich. Ich weiß es auch nicht mehr. Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Genau, ich weiß, mein halbes Leben wusste ich es falsch und dann der halbes Leben richtig. Ich weiß jetzt aber nicht mehr, was was war, ob ich jetzt noch wieder korrigieren muss oder nicht. Das ist immer so, wenn man weiß, ah, ich weiß, das ist genauso wie Stalagmieten, Stalag Tieten. Das weiß ich. Ich weiß, eins war so, aber vielleicht ist es auch genau andersrum und dann hilft es dir gar nichts. Nee, das habe ich mir gemerkt, mit diesem Dreckigen, wo ich mich immer für hasse.
Aber Titen, was so klingt wie Titen, Titen hängen herab. Dadurch weise ich das Schlag Titen. Und ich möchte mich in aller Form dafür entschuldigen. Ich mag mich selber nicht für diese Eselsbrücke. Es ist keine schöne Eselsbrücke, aber so merke ich mir das immer. Deswegen bin ich auch immer leise, wenn es um Stalag-Mieten-Schneidigen geht, weil ich will nicht derjenige sagen, der es weiß, weil ich so eine peinliche Eselsbrücke habe. Vielleicht fällt es eine bessere ein. Wir können ja sagen, Stalag-Mieten sind wie die Mieten, die gehen immer hoch. Die Mieten? Die Wohnungsmieten. Aber Mietpreis Leckel. Ja, gut. Aber man kann ja sagen, die Mieten steigen nach oben, also sind Stalagmieten die, die unten sind. Tieten, wie Tietze, der oben ist, weil er gross ist. Ja, aber der will ja nicht runter. Der will nicht runter, aber der ist auch gross. Der will ja hoch. Nee, hoch und runter ist, naja. Man schaut nach oben zum Tietze. Stimmt, das Problem ist, kann man nicht sagen, ah, Stalagmiten, die Mieten sind hoch, also ist es oben.
Na, fuck. Es ist perfekt. Es ist, meine Eselsbrücke ist perfekt, hat mich noch nicht im Stich gelassen. Aber das finde ich nicht schlecht, eine Eselsbrücke, die einem unangenehm ist. Und deswegen, wenn ich mal so einen Test vor mir liegen habe, ich werde es falsch ankreuzen, extra, weil ich will es nicht wissen. Ja, Wann hast du mal zuletzt so eine schöne Sonntagsaktivität gemacht, wie so in die Höhle, in die Tropfsteinhöhle zu gehen? Boah, solche Aktivitäten, da tue ich mir immer schwer, da tue ich mich wirklich schwer, dann mal wirklich mal wo hinzugehen, jetzt mal heute Abend Lasertag oder da mal jetzt hingehen, das ist, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie fühle ich mich der Unwohl. So soll man sagen,, ich bin jetzt Pen and Paper oder so, so was regelmässiges, aber so mal, ja, wir gehen jetzt da hin, so Aktivitäten, das finde ich immer unangenehm irgendwie. Ich mag nicht diese Unterhaltungsindustrie, so wo dann jemand ist, der macht ja dann so ein Zuckerwattentier oder so, ich will das nicht, ich finde das irgendwie immer unangenehm. Ich finde es toll. Das ist so dieses ich mag mich nicht amüsieren.
Ich mag, also dieses, verstehst du,
ich mag Spaß haben, ich mag Spaß,
love it, aber ich will mich nicht
amüsieren. Spaß von mir, fünf von fünf Sterne.
Ja, Spaß ist super, aber amüsieren
eher so eine Eins von fünf.
Ich mag mich amüsieren,
so... Das ist auf Knopfdruck, ne?
Ja, man fährt da hin und jetzt bitte amüsieren und dann fahrt er auchüsieren. Und im Auto regt man sich noch auf über den Verkehr und über das Wetter. Und dann ist man sehr schlecht gelangt, kommt dann da an und hat man diese Pflicht, aber jetzt Spaß haben zu müssen. Das ist zu viel Druck. Das ist so wie diese bemitleidenswerten Menschen, die in Disney World sind und die völlig gestresst sind von einer Attraktion zur anderen, wetzen, weil sie sagen, wir müssen jetzt den Tag nutzen, wir müssen unbedingt das nutzen, oh schnell, wir müssen da hin, oh wir können jetzt nicht irgendwie kurz uns mal hinsetzen, sondern wir müssen direkt da hin. Das ist für mich so der Inbegriff von diesem Amüsieren, wir fahren jetzt hin, um uns zu amüsieren. Da muss jetzt was passieren. Du beschreibst für mich Silvester.
Das ist eine Datum,
wo man gut drauf sein muss,
wo man feiern muss, wo man sich um seine Abendaktivität kümmern muss.
Da ist so viel, da schwingt
so viel Pflicht mit.
Man macht sich auch sehr viel Druck.
Auf der anderen Seite habe ich aber es total, ich mag das total,
wenn der ganze Ort dafür da ist,
dass es dir gerade gut geht.
Der Eingang ist schon toll designt, und da kommt man
da rein und alles, da gibt es einen Parkplan
und dann geht man da rum
Vielen Dank. wenn der ganze Ort dafür da ist, dass es dir gerade gut geht. Der Eingang ist schon toll designt und dann kommt man da rein und alles, da gibt es einen Parkplan und dann geht man da rum und überall sind Sachen, wo man sich viel Mühe reingeflossen ist. Das ist ja wie einen Film gucken. Das könnte vielleicht auch mal eine nächste Phase sein, habe ich gedacht, Freizeitparks. Vielleicht will ich auch mal arbeiten im Freizeitpark. Das ist mein größter Wunsch eigentlich immer. Ich dachte, also wenn ich nicht das gemacht hätte, was jetzt mache, dachte ich vielleicht Architekt, finde ich auch super. Oder danach, aber auch schon auf Platz drei, Achterbahn, Bügelrüttler, die gucken, ob die Bügel festsitzen. Ja, finde ich gut. Und immer ein schönes Kostüm anhaben, passend zum Theming der Achterbahn. Ja, es gibt ja Avatar-World, du bist ja riesen Avatar-Fan. Und gross. Und ich könnte in diesem Navi auch. Ja, das ist nämlich das grosse Problem, dass du dieses Avatar-Land hast. Ich glaube, das ist sogar Teil von Disney World, dass die das Avatar-Franchise gekauft haben. Und dann können die aber keine Avatar-Figuren, also keine Navi tatsächlich einsetzen im Park, weil die halt gross sind. Und deswegen müssen die alles so, die Navi haben hier mal gelebt und früher und so und die sind da in so einer Welt, wo die das, worum es geht, nicht zeigen und das ist ganz merkwürdig, auch nicht sehr erfolgreich, weil auch niemand Avatar mag irgendwie, also aber es ist eine ganz merkwürdige, merkwürdige Welt, wo man nicht das kriegt, was man will, aber man geht da extra hin und die Leute sagen immer, ah, haben sie die Dokumentation gesehen, womit sie den Avatar-Film meinen, aber man ist in so einer Art Rolle drin, wo man gewisse Dinge nicht sagt. Gott, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ja, genauso wie man im Star-Wars-Land auch nicht Toilette sagt, sondern The Refresher oder sowas, The Refreshment Facility oder irgendwie sowas. Und so Kantine-Taverne, zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel. Aber welches Franchise könntest du dir vorstellen, wenn du jetzt sagst, du baust einen neuen Vergnügungspark und wir wissen alle, Mickey Mouse ist weg, Harry Potter ist weg, Avatar ist weg, Star Wars ist weg. Sagst du, es braucht ein geiles Franchise, wo man einen guten, aus welchem Franchise kann man einen Mein Pitch, ich würde eine Rick and Morty verschiedene Dimensionen, verschiedene Universen, Franchise machen, aber ohne es zu sehr Rick and Morty zu benennen. Ich würde einfach nur, dann ist da plötzlich ein Restaurant, das man auch gehen kann in dieser Welt, wo einen Hot Dogs bedienen und kleine Menschen drin liegen. Ja, okay. Ja, also wo heißt ... Genau, und jede Tür ist wie so ein Portal, was Rick immer schießt mit seiner Knarre, da geht man dann durch und ist dann wieder in einer anderen Welt, wo alles merkwürdig ist, wo Hunde mit Menschen gehen, Menschen mit Hunde gehen, wo Räuber der Polizei hinterherlaufen. Ich möchte, das ist einfach ein Weird Land, wo einfach alles anders ist Und hinter jeder Tür ist eine neue Dimension, wo andere Dinge komisch sind. Auch die Musik, die da läuft, ist seltsam. Das heißt, die Zielgruppen sind aber auch nicht Kinder, wie normalerweise bei Vögelgungspark. Nee, Rick and Morty Fans, so Sci-Fi Fans, so Meta-Meter-Fans. Also so Mitzwanziger, Menschen, die sich besonders klug fühlen, die dann da hingehen und auf ironische Art Spaß haben. Genau, dann fährt man mit der Achterbahn und stellt sich danach an. Am Ausgang muss man sich anstellen. Du musst am Ausgang warten, nicht am Eingang. Du musst am Ausgang warten. Du musst sofort rein, musst dann aber noch 40 Minuten am Ausgang warten. Richtig, genau. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Und alles ist ein bisschen seltsam und merkwürdig. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Das wäre mein Pitch in Park. Nee, was ich dachte die ganze Zeit, warum gibt es das nicht eigentlich? Das nächste ist vielleicht so was wie Live-Action-Role-Playing-Events oder sowas, aber in Deutschland gibt es doch wahnsinnig viele Burgen. Schöne Burgen. So, da kann man doch mal hin, und warum leben da nicht nur dann so, keine Ahnung, 50 Schauspieler oder sowas? Und man holt quasi, man macht Westworld, nur diesen Tötenaspekt, dass man nicht auf die Leute schießen kann. Aber warum macht man nicht Westworld in Middle Ages World in Deutschland irgendwo in so einer Burg und kann dann da wirklich mal eine Woche sich einchecken, lebt dann da quasi, kriegst eine Backstory vorher und so ein cooles Outfit, was du dir wählen kannst, dann gehst du da hin, fährst du auf dem Pferd und die sagen, oh, wer sind sie denn? Ich weiß nicht, ob wir sie reinlassen können. Du sagst, ich komme aus den Niederlanden. Coole Backstory. Ich bin der Baron von Oranien. Ich glaube, du begründest gerade selber, warum es sowas nicht gibt, weil die meisten Leute nicht so gute Rollenspieler sind. Nein, die bekommen noch Backstories genannt und so, die muss man auch nicht lernen. Ein bisschen sowas gibt es ja als Mittelalter-Märkten, wo ich ja auch ab und zu war als Kind. Und Kaltenberger Ritter-Turnier war ich schön dabei. Und da gibt es ja auch Leute, die dann wirklich auch in Character sind und so. Ich weiß noch, da hatte ich dann so ein Schwert dabei, weil mein Bruder auch dabei war. Aber ich will diesen Park-Event, dieses Amüsier-Event.
Ja. Ich möchte mich einchecken, ich möchte da in die Burg gehen und so und dann zeigt mir dann das Burgfräulein mein Gemach, weil ich geflohen bin. Ich bin der einzige Überlebende von der Schlacht von ... Ach, es geht alles nur um dich. Du bist der einzige Gast. Nee, es sind schon ein paar andere Gäste da. Okay ist was los, sage ich Ihnen. Heute hat eine ganze Gruppe von kleinen Kindern sich hier anderes Wort für eingecheckt. Und dann ist man da und man denkt, auch keine Kinder. Vielleicht ist Lab was für dich. So ein Wochenende, so auf Burgen gibt es tatsächlich relativ oft Labs, wo du so ein Wochenende... Ich schlafe in Zelten, in so Decathlon-Zelten. Ja gut, okay, verstehe. Du willst den Komfort von Disneyland, aber die Immersionen von Larps. Nee, nee, ich will auch nicht den Komfort von Disneyland, ich will fucking Mittelalter, all the way. Ja, aber dann ist doch das Richtige für dich. In Larps schlafen wir doch in fucking diesen Zelten, diesen Plastikzelten. Nein, nein, nein. Die haben die alten Zelte? Ja, klar. So richtige K richtige Kuhleder, Kuhfeldzelte. Also es kommt halt darauf an, es gibt wahrscheinlich auch andere, die da nicht so viel Wert drauflegen, aber an sich schon. Ach was, so muss ich nicht. Vielleicht ist das die nächste Phase, Lab, dass du mal wieder auf so ein Mittelalter Lab gehst und dich da so ein bisschen austobst und dann mit Schaumstoffschwertern rumklopst. Aber dann musst du halt so mega drin sein. Ich dachte auch, dass du, du kannst dann was erleben. Nachts hörst du zum Beispiel einen Schrei in der Burg. Und dann kannst du halt beschließen, auszuschlafen. Oder du kannst beschließen, diesen Quest wahrzunehmen und dann kurz rauszugehen und, ah, habt ihr den Schrei gehört und so. Oder du kannst auch in Bukarest machen oder so. Und dann machst du da so einen Transsilvanien-themed Fun-Helzing-Experience. Ja. Mega. Ja. Und nachts siehst du so Blitze oben rauskommen. Am nächsten Morgen kannst du beim Frühstück dann an der großen Tafel dann fragen, habt ihr gestern auch diese Blitze gehört? Und der Gastgeber so, darüber wird nicht mehr gesprochen. Man weiss, na, das ist ein fucking Quest. Das ist ein fucking Quest. Und dann reist man immer wieder dahin, jedes Jahr, weil man diesen Quest immer noch nicht gelöst hat. Und man tauscht sich so Foren aus, wo er rauskam, hat jemals diese Blitze oben auf den Grund gegangen und alle so, nee, das hat nie geklappt. Warum sind die Fledermäuser wieder in die Burg zurückgekehrt? Der Baron hat auch gesagt, dass sie vor zwei Jahren hier weg sind. Warum sind sie jetzt plötzlich wieder hier? Das habe ich 2013 gelöst. Da habe ich dann auch so einen Merge-Artikel bekommen, wenn ich den Quest gelöst habe. Verstehe, so immersiv. Ich verstehe, so gute Idee. Und es ist mehr auch für mich. Ich will nicht bei diesem Lab, da sind dann alle Charakter und alle haben Spaß. Ich will, dass ich Spaß habe und alle anderen Schauspieler sind. Alle anderen dir zuarbeiten, okay, verstehen. Ja, oder den ein paar Leuten, die dann da sind, zuarbeiten. Ja, aber es ist eher so ein Freizeitpark-Ding. Und da möchte ich wirklich mal wissen, warum es das nicht. Und bist du da noch ein Fledermars Achterbahn? Klar. Okay. Also du, Mittelalter Rätsel, aber trotzdem auch noch die Achterbahn. Die nimmst du noch mit. Die will ich nicht missen. Und schön Slushy ist auch dabei. Slushy-Bude. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Die Immersion bricht immer ab einem gewissen Punkt ein. Kaltemberg-Ritter-Turnier war ich auch oft, da hatte ich dann so ein Schwert dabei und habe dann gegen so einen Baum geschlagen.
Und dann ist auch einer von den Leuten so ein kompletter Ritter-Montur zu mir gegangen, hat mir so die Hand auf die Schulter gelegt und hat gesagt, man schlägt keine Bäume, das sagen die Kelten. Und ich sagte mir, okay, seitdem habe ich nie wieder einen Baum geschlagen. Hast du dann ihn geschlagen? Nein, nein, nein. Nein, aber ich war da glaube ich auch zu sehr in Fantasy drin. Also ich hatte auch Stich dabei von Herr der Ringe und habe für Gondor gerufen. Ich glaube, ich bin den Leuten da ziemlich auf die Nerven gerufen. Ja, das glaube ich auch, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, das funktioniert so nicht gut. Aber nehmen die denn, ja gut, Kelten und du sagst für Gondor, dann ist doch auch schon die ganze Welt zusammengebalanzt. Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Ah, aber reden die schon von den Städten, die es damals gab? Ja, ich glaube schon, ich weiß nicht, ob man die damals Kelten genannt hat, ehrlich gesagt, aber keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Ich war zwölf Jahre alt, ich konnte das nicht so gut factchecken. Das haben die alten Kelten gesagt. Du hast gesagt, wieso alt? Und ja, die haben ja vor 200 Jahren gelebt, oder? Oder in 200? Die leben jetzt. Und du sagst, ich will weiter auf meinen Baum einschlagen, okay? Und er sagt, okay. Ich führe bessere Gespräche mit diesem Baum als mit euch. Ja, also kannst du machen. Immer dieses Irzen, dass man irbt. Euch. Euch. Vielleicht machen wir irgendwann noch unser Pen and Paper, dann kannst du zumindest da mal in eine Fantasywelt einsteigen. Können wir noch machen, brauchen wir noch richtige Leute. Vielleicht kriegen wir Frank Schacht dazu mitzumachen, vielleicht kriegen wir ihn in so einer Art Gedächtnisspirale, wenn wir mit ihm in die Vergangenheit reisen, irgendwie in die... Wir können ja auch so ein Pen and Paper in den 90ern machen, wo er Ocean's Eleven übersetzt hat. Vielleicht kommt da die Erinnerung zurück. Ja, finde ich gut. Wir machen ganz viele Sendungen mit Frank Schacht, nur um ihn so ein bisschen dahin zu nudgen, dass er vielleicht sein Gedächtnis wird. Ich glaube, wenn man das so formuliert. Wir massieren sein Gehirn. Ja, genau. Er kriegt eine Kopfmassage, so Gedächtnistrainingseinheiten und so was und denkt sich, warum laden die mich immer wieder in ihren Podcast ein? Was ist da los?
Es war eingefallen, ich habe damals mal eine Lehrerin von mir geirzt, einfach weil ich das lustig fand.
Für einen Tag habe ich immer gesagt, kann ich euch noch was bringen, könntet ihr das nochmal wiederholen?
Und irgendwann hat sie gesagt, woher weißt du das?
Und ich so, wie, was?
Und dann sie ist vor die Klasse gestellt und hat gesagt, ja, ich bin schwanger. Und ich so, was? Die war auch angepisst die ganze Zeit, ich habe nicht verstanden, warum kam raus, sie dachte, ich duze sie in der Pluralform und sie ist schwanger und ich rede die ganze Zeit von euch beiden. Wow, das ist der beste Twist der Geschichte. Was aber auch mega ruiert wäre, wenn ich das gewusst hätte, dann plötzlich anfangen sie zu duzen und sie dann sagen, ja, kann ich euch noch was geben? Und sie dann denkt, vor allem wie fucking gemein auch. Aber wie hart um die Ecke auch, weil es ja nicht gängig, dass man schwangere Menschen null, es ist doch voll daneben, es ist voll daneben. Weil sie ist ja immer noch sie. Aber was war das für ein Moment, der beste Detektiv der Welt oder er hat einfach fucking Glück genau in dem Moment. Oder er irrt sie genau an dem Tag. Wow. Woher weißt du das? Grossartig. Vor allem, als ich bin schwanger und ich so, ja und jetzt zurück zu gerade.
Warum waren Sie gerade so verwirrt? Wie, was, woher weiß ich was? Weil ich hab auch nicht gecheckt, weil das ist ja um die Ecke, das ist ja tausendmal um die Ecke, und die ganze Klasse so, was? Weil die Klasse, ich hab, es war ja auch kein guter Gag, ich hab einfach Bock gehabt, man plötzlich zu irzen. Warst du so ein bisschen Störnfried oder was? Nee, manchmal war ich ein bisschen, habe ich mir auch lustige Ideen gehabt, dachte ich. Ich dachte, der alte Stefan war gar nicht lustig. Ich habe letztens einen Podcast mit dir gehört, da hast du erzählt, der alte Stefan war viel zu verbissen. Und damals, wenn man sich die ganzen X-Faktor-Sachen anguckt, war es ja auch eher so der Mädchenschwarm und so und gab er gar nicht der Lust. Aber das war ja so mit 16 rum und so und dann plötzlich die letzten beiden Jahre im Gymnasium, da kam das dann so.
Ach stimmt, du warst ja erst vor ein paar Jahren in der Schule.
Ich war vor ein paar Jahren in der Schule.
Die ersten beiden Jahre, da hat man dann angefangen, so Humor ein bisschen zu sich zu erdenken.
Und ein erster Gehversuch war es, an einem Tag alle Lehrer zu irzen.
Woher warst du das? Das ist schon gut. Das fand ich auch nicht so schlecht. Schulstory. Wow. Wow, so was haben wir nie erlebt. So was Krasses. Nee, aber so mit den Lehrern, so Streichel mit den Lehrern oder so, habe ich nie gemacht. Nee, dann eher so. Nee, dann habe ich auch nicht so Sachen gemacht. Aber ich habemals ein paar alte Aufzeichnungen gefunden aus der Schulzeit, wo wir so verschiedene Gedichte geschrieben haben und so und so ein paar Gags und so die ersten Gehversuche. Habe ich jetzt auch überlegt, ob ich das den Leuten nochmal schicken soll, so meinen ehemaligen Klassenkameraden, weil ich habe das alles gesammelt, weil ich das interessant fand. Und dann so, hier guck mal, das hast du in deiner Schulzeit geschrieben, da hast du Gedichte geschrieben. Und heute bist du ein zynischer, verbissener, verbitterter, traumloser, festgefahrener, langweiliger Mensch.
So als Weihnachtskarte, finde ich es gut.
Aber damals warst du voller Hoffnung und kreativer Spritzigkeit, tolle Reime.
Tolle Reime.
Richtig tolle Reime. Was reibst du heute noch?
Was ist dann passiert?
Wo bist du falsch abgebogen? Liebe Grüße von der ganzen Familie Will, frohe Weihnachten. Die Plätzchen selber gebacken, das soll schminken. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Aber auch so dieses, wann sagt man wem was auch irgendwie so, auch wenn jemand stirbt. Bitte? Wenn jemand stirbt, sagt man das dann den Klassen, auf Facebook habe ich noch so ein paar alte Klassenkameraden, angenommen jetzt irgendjemand aus der Klasse stirbt, sagt man das dann denen allen so, hey, übrigens wir haben uns seit zwölf Jahren nicht gesprochen, aber Hugo ist tot, ciao. Ja, wenn wir uns alle kannten, dann würde ich sagen, wer würde man das schon sagen. Ein Klassikammerat ist gestorben?
Nein, ist nie mehr gestorben, noch nicht.
Aber schon langsam müsste man eigentlich.
Statistisch gesehen ja.
Statistisch gesehen wird es langsam eng.
Wir hatten 250 Leute in der Stufe, da ist dann noch nichts passiert, das wundert mich schon sehr.
Ich habe ein zehnjähriges Abi-Jubiläum und ganz ehrlich, ich freue mich wahnsinnig darauf, die alten Klausuren einsehen zu können.
Nach zehn Jahren sind die Abi-Klausuren nicht mehr unter Verschluss und 2023 kann ich in den Kerker in Verlies 237 und dann wird das aufgeschlossen aufwendig und dann kriege ich da meine versiegelten Abiklausuren. Aber werden die dann irgendwann verbrannt oder werden die für immer aufgehoben? Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum man da so eine magische Welt aufmachen muss. Wir verbrennen jetzt in der Walpurgis-Nacht dann diese ganzen Klausuren. Nein, gib mir das doch einfach nach Hause. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich meinen noch abholen könnte. Sag das doch mal früher, Mensch. Wenn es zehn Jahre her ist. Ja, aber die Frage ist, gibt es irgendwann auch maximal Limit, dass sie nach 20 Jahren verbrannt werden oder so? Ich glaube, es gibt ein Fenster, ja.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das Fenster nicht verpasst.
Ich glaube, der Fenster ist zu.
Mal so die alte Deutschklausur nochmal lesen.
Ja, Deutsch freue ich mich sehr drauf.
Oh Gott, so viel Bullshit einfach.
Da habe ich über Stilmittelanalyse und der ganze Kram.
Tauben im Gras gesprochen, freue mich sehr drauf, mochte ich auch wahnsinnig gerne das Buch.
Und das Höhlengleichnis freue mich auch drauf, darüber ein bisschen was zu lesen, nochmal in Philo. Ich glaube, wenn man das so liest, fühlt man sich richtig dumm. Ich glaube, man war damals auf seinem Peak. Und jetzt gerade, weil ich habe ja auch Mathe-Abi geschrieben, ich glaube, ich könnte das nicht mal mehr in die Art verziehen, was da passiert. Und ich habe ein gutes Mathe-Abi geschrieben und ich werde das lesen und denken, das kann ein fucking Genie sein. Das ist ein Genie. Das ist brillant.
Das ist brillant.
Diese Beweisführung.
Und dann blättert man es so durch und dann setzt man so eine Montagemusik ein und dann nimmt man diesen Zettel und läuft zum Mathematischen Institut in Leipzig und legt es da hin und sagt, lesen Sie das durch.
Und die sagen, das ist ein Matheabitler oder so.
Naja, aber hier, der hat die eine Gleichung in die andere eingesetzt. Ja, das macht man einfach, das ist ganz normal, die Aufgabenstellung. Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen noch einen schönen Tag, Herr Professor. Das will ich mal. Ich würde das nehmen und sagen, diese Beweisführung, er hat die Antwort gefunden, ja, das war auch die Idee. Man ist so dumm geworden, man ist so dumm geworden. Wann glaubst du, ist es bei dir bergab gegangen? Was ist der Moment, wo es bei dir bergab gegangen ist? Ich glaube, mit dem Abi-Klingeln, Schulhof-Klingeln war es vorbei. Dann ging alles bergab. Ich bin mal gesprungen, wollte in den Raum springen und bin dabei mit dem Kopf ganz doll gegen die Türschwelle oben gestiegen.
Wie muss man sich denn diesen Störenfried Stefan vorstellen? Ärgert die Lehrerin und springt in den Klassenraum?
Das war nicht in der Schule. Das war nicht in der Schule. Das war irgendwie zu Hause mit Freunden gespielt und wollte dann in das Zimmer springen.
Mit Freunden gespielt?
Ja.
Wie, einfach getollt oder was? Getollt? Gezockt, Buden gebaut und gezockt. Ich bin in einen Raum gesprungen, um zu sagen, so Kramer-artig, und bin dabei aber mit meinem Kopf gegen die Tür geschlagen. Du wolltest einen coolen Auftritt machen. Das war, glaube ich, der Moment, wo es bergab ging mit mir. Ab da hat sich mein Kopf zurückentwickelt.
Danach geht es bergab. Nur noch ersetzt durch unnützes Wissen. Nur noch über
Freizeitparks und Segelscheine und Fischsorten.
Ja, und das für zwei Wochen und dann ist es ja auch
weg. Dann muss das nächste kommen, um diese
klaffende Lücke zu füllen.
Schau mal vielleicht, dass du irgendwas
benennst. Dass du irgendwann nochmal den Tietze-Effekt
oder die Tietze-Strasse oder irgendwie sowas in der
Richtung, die Tietze-Strahlung oder sowas in der Richtung.
Problem, es gibt ein Element vielleicht.
Das Tize-Syndrom gibt es schon.
Oh.
Es gibt das Tize-Syndrom, ich muss mal kurz heraus...
Ach, Syndrom ist somit das Beste, was man haben will.
Ja.
Syndrom ist auch einfach ein Wort. Das Tize-Syndrom.
Beim Tize-Syndrom handelt es sich um eine seltene und druckschmerzhafte Schwellung unbekannte Ursache, die meist im Bereich des Brustbeinansatzes auftritt und binnen Monat wieder auszahlt, es gibt keine Anzeichen für eine Entzündung. Erst beschreiber war Alexander Tietze, 1927 gestorben, mit seiner 1921 erschienenen Arbeit über eine eigenartige Häufung von Fällen
mit Dystrophie und Rippenknorpel in der Berliner Klinischen Wochenzeitschrift. Das Syndrom ist nicht so weit wie mit dem Tietz-Syndrom. Also hier geht es offenbar drunter und drüber. Moment, es gibt zwei Tietz-Syndrome. Das Tietz-Syndrom gibt es auch noch. Ach Tietz, ach Gott. Das ist Albinismus und Taubheit kombiniert. Tritt das so häufig auf, dass man da noch mal ein eigenes Wort hat? Albinismus und taub, weiß und taub? Deutsch-US-amerikanischer Kinderarzt Walter Tietz. Oh Mann, wenn es sich erwischt, dann dann haben wir auch richtig Weiss und Taub.
Was für eine weirde Kombination. Aber jetzt kann ja jeder sagen, Moment, du hast so eine Grippe und bist erkältet, Tiesesyndrom. Ja, das ist halt dieses alte Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Ding, dass du Sachen beliebig variieren kannst. Dass du sagst, ich bin der, der die 100 Meter am schnellsten joggt, während er jongliert. Ja. Ja, und dann schlägt sich jemand und dann sagt sie, ja, ich renne die hundert Meter, während ich ein lustiges Taschenbuch lese. Ja, sind im Buch. Ja, sie sind im Buch. Sie haben die fünfzigste Seite. Ja, sie sind in unserem langweiligen Kackbuch, in dem Guinness-Buch der Rekorde Varianten. Ja, Läng. Also auch so überhaupt nicht glitzert und Null-3D-Effekt, sondern so ein ganz trockenes Heftchen. Jetzt hat es was Flyerhaftes. Dicker Flyer. Aber so ein Heftchen, wo die Seiten auch rechts noch so zusammengestanzt sind, wo man die einzelnen so abreißen muss. Und ganz klein gedruckt. Ganz klein, keine Fotos, keine Bilder. Ganz nützlich, keine Bilder, nur Namen, einfach nur Namen, was gemacht. Und diese dünnen Seiten, wie man es von Bibeln kennt. Ja, genau. Wo man auch schon, wenn man das Licht hält, kann man nichts lesen, weil man von hinten die Schrift auch noch sieht. Ja, so diese Schundhefte einfach. Gab es noch Neuigkeiten von Bibeln? Ne, nichts. Ach, da kommen immer wieder Sachen, Leute finden Bibelsachen. Ich muss auch noch ein bisschen was aufräumen von letzter Woche, beziehungsweise letzten Wochen hat uns ja beschäftigt, gibt man Trinkgeld online oder gibt man es direkt in bar auf die Kralle. Und wir haben eigentlich gehört, es kommt bei Lieferando zumindest in grossen Teilen immer komplett an, aber halt erst nach der Transaktion, was es gesellschaftlich ein bisschen weird macht, weil die beleidigen einen im Treppenhaus und kriegen dann unten am Handy angezeigt, nee, der hat Trinkgeld gegeben. Und dann wird eine Entschuldigung geflüstert, aber es ist trotzdem eine unangenehme gesellschaftliche Interaktion. So, jetzt haben wir aber einen Whistleblower am Start, der nicht von Lieferando kommt, sondern von Dominos. Lieferando haben wir gehört, Lieferando zahlt das eins zu eins aus. Ist zwar nicht so schön und so genau nachvollziehbar, ist es auch nicht unbedingt und man soll es lieber bargeben, das ist der Disclaimer, aber Lieferando macht es zumindest einigermaßen fair, wie wir herausgefunden haben. Aber nicht so bei Dominos. Ich arbeite bei Dominos und wir haben noch nie etwas von dem Lieferando-Trinkgeld gesehen. Es wurde mal behauptet, dass es nur 40 Euro im Monat wären und davon die Lieferando-Gebühren bezahlt wären. Abgesehen davon, dass das schon illegal ist, kann das nicht stimmen, da wir jede Schicht mehrere tausend Euro über Online-Bestellungen machen. Deshalb am besten immer bar auf die Hand. Heißt, ich verrate jetzt nicht den Namen, vielen Dank an dich, lieber Whistleblower, aber das Podcast-Ufo-Investigativ nach Recherchen von Süddeutscher, Westdeutscher und Zeitung und das Podcast-Ufo könnte jetzt ein Domino-Effekt in Gang treten, der zu einem handfesten Skandal führt. Genau, Domino-Pizza ist offensichtlich dabei. Unterschlägt Trinkgeld. Unterschlägt Trinkgeld in Höhe von tausenden Euros. Das ist ein waschechter Skandal. Wie gehen wir weiter vor? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich traue mich da nicht anzurufen. Nee, das ist echt unangenehm. Wir können eine Online-Bestellung machen. Nee, wir können da mal anrufen, tatsächlich, bei Dominos. Aber wenn man Dominos Telefonnummer googelt, glaube ich, hat man nicht die richtigen in der Strippe, wenn du verstehst, was ich meine. Naja, wir müssten Kontakt zum Whistleblower aufnehmen eigentlich, dass der uns mehr Insights gibt. Aber das ist doch die, das ist die Insights, die wir brauchen. Eigentlich müssten wir ja
doch jetzt schon den Lieferant, äh, Dominos
kritisieren, direkt anrufen, direkt konfrontieren.
Sollen wir es machen?
Wir wollten mal fragen, ob das Trinkgeld, ich bin ja schon nervös,
wir wollten mal vorsichtig nachfragen,
ob das ganze Trinkgeld, was man
online gibt, über zum Beispiel Lieferando-Apps, komplett bei Ihren Fahrern ankommt. Ja. Können Sie uns das schriftlich geben? Ja, gerne. Echt jetzt? Investigativer Journalist, der man jetzt sagt, echt jetzt? Echt jetzt? Stimme aber schlecht sich achtmal, macht einen doppelten Rittberger. Ja, ich kann ihn auch ja schriftlich geben, kann ich ihn geben, ja. Nee, schon mit der Frage davor. Ja, machen wir, das machen wir nächste Woche, dann muss ich mich sehr, ich rauf auf Aureiten. Aber dann rufen wir die live an. Das hat jetzt noch eine Woche Zeit, die wurden schon so lange beschissen, die Leute da. Aber ist ein heißes Thema, wir müssen natürlich auch aufpassen, dass wir uns da nicht in juristische Schwierigkeiten hineinmanövrieren.
Wieso?
Naja, wenn wir da jetzt anrufen und das Illegale aufzeichnen, was die sagen und das als Statement benutzen und so.
Wir müssen unsere Anwälte, die wir nicht haben, einschalten, was wir nicht können.
Wir müssen Thais einschalten. Das ist eigentlich ein Fall für Thais.
Thais ist doch unsere Investigativjournalistin.
Thais-Digativ?
Thais-Digativ. Alter, das ist gut. Ich schreibe ihr heute noch. Sie soll einen Beitrag dazu machen, sie soll das klären. Ja, die hat schon blockiert, schon lange. Sie soll die alle vor Gericht zerren und am Ende Pulitzerpreis. Thais kriegt den Pulitzerpreis, wir kriegen den, aber sie holt den ab, wie den Podcastpreis. Sie behält ihn dann. Sie behält ihn wie den Podcastpreis, den wir bis heute nicht gesehen haben. Fände ich super. Und ich würde sagen, nahmen wir noch einen guten Cliffhanger für nächste Woche, wo es heißt, Dominos, wir machen euch den Gare aus. Ja, wir können auch noch in eine kurze Humorlupe reinlunsen. Okay. Ich weiß nicht, ob es sich lohnt, es ist eine Menge. Aber Simon hat uns geschrieben und Simon hat gegraben in den theologischen Werken dieser Kultur und hat geschrieben.
Hallo Stefan Florentin. Beim Hören der letzten Folge kam mir zwar indirekt relativ unverständlicher Witz aus dem frühen Prinzipat in den Sinn.
Also um es kurz bibeltechnisch einzuordnen, wir sind im Prinzipat im frühen Prinzipat. Wunderbar.
Suetons Vespians Vita ist zwar nicht...
Bitte? Das ist Latein.
Suetons Vespasian Vita ist zwar nicht direkt die Bibel, aber die beschriebene Situation spielt Ende der 70er Jahre des ersten Jahrhunderts und damit nur wenige Jahrzehnte nach Jesu Tod. Also, wir sind hier im Extended Cut, wir sind hier im Directors Cut der Bibel. Also es sind noch ein paar Szenen hinzugefügt worden. Es geht um Sueton. Sueton schrieb die Vita circa 100 bis 120 Jahre nach Christus. Okay? Also jemand 100 Jahre nach Christus bezieht sich auf die 70er Jahre des ersten Jahrhunderts. Genau, die 70er Jahre, 70 nach Christus. Wenige Jahre nach Jesu Tod. Jesus ist ja ungefähr so mit Mitte 40. 30 nach. Mitte 30, ähm, wie war das jetzt geschoben? Abgehauen, weggefahren. Gehen Himmel gefahren. Gehen Himmel gefahren. So, jetzt aber zum Witz, jetzt kommt der Witz, Achtung. In Sueton Vesp 25, drei bis vier steht folgendes über Vespasian. Vespasian. Vespasian. Als ihm einmal seinen Sohn Titus vorhielt, dass er auch noch eine Pissoir-Steuer plane, hielt er ihm das Geld aus der ersten Zahlung unter die Nase und wollte wissen, ob er am Geruch Anstoß nehme. Als jener das verneinte, sagte er, und doch kommt es vom Urin. Als ihm Gesandte meldeten, man habe beschlossen, ihm im Namen des Staates für eine nicht gerade kleine Summe eine riesige Statue zu errichten, befahl er ihnen, sie möglichst sofort aufzustellen, hielt ihnen seine hohle Hand hin und sagte, der Sockel ist fertig. Und er machte sogar seine Scherze, wenn er Angst hatte und in höchster Lebensgefahr war, als sich nämlich plötzlich das Mausoleum öffnete und ein Komet am Himmel auftauchte. Zwei unter vielen anderen Vorzeichen. Sagte er, dass eine Vorzeichen betreffe die Iunia Calvina. Boah, Leute, das ist der längste Satz der Welt. Dass man an deiner Betonung merkt, dass du nicht annähernden Ahnung hast, wo im Satz du gerade bist. Ich glaube, das geht hier direkt, es ist direkt der Text aus diesem Werk, das ist kompliziert. Und er machte sogar seine Scherze, wenn er Angst hatte und in höchster Lebensgefahr war. Als sich nämlich plötzlich das Mausoleum öffnete und ein Komet am Himmel auftauchte, zwei unter vielen anderen Vorzeichen, sagte er, dass eine Vorzeichen betreffe die Junia Calvina aus dem Geschlecht des Augustus, das andere den Parterkönig, der das Haar lang trägt. Auch beim ersten Anfall einer Krankheit sagte er, ach, ich glaube, ich werde ein Gott. Also, wo ist hier jetzt der Witz? Das war's vom Stand Up, wir wir haben jetzt noch heute Abend zu Gast, Johannes der Täufer und Special Musik-Guest. Also ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass dieser Vespasian, dem ist alles egal, der hat keine Angst vor niemandem und selbst wenn ein Komet am Himmel erscheint, sagt er, das ist bestimmt ein Vorzeichen für jemand anderen.
Also so muss man sich diese Figur vorstellen. Keine Angst vor Gott, keine Angst vor Konsequenzen.
Krasser Typ, so ein bisschen John Wick-mässig, sehe ich ihn jetzt gerade. So, wo ist hier der Witz? Der erste Teil über die Pissoir... Kannst du das mal vorlesen? Ich glaube, es sind zwei Teile. Einmal gibt es eine Pissoir-Steuer und irgendjemand sagt ihm, willst du das Geld hier haben, es kommt vom Urin, aber riecht nicht danach, irgendwie so ein bisschen, es sei Blutgeld irgendwie, sowas in der Richtung. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was damit gemeint ist, aber egal, lass uns die Erklärung kommen von Simon. Wo ist hier also der Witz von Simon? Der erste Teil über die Pissoirsteuer ist noch relativ klar. Darauf geht auch das heutige Sprichwort Geld stinkt nicht zurück. Möglich ist das eine reine Behauptung, aber gut. Der zweite Teil ist aber etwas umständlich. Aber auch hier gibt es teilweise eine Erklärung. Also wir haben hier mit Bruchstücken von Witzen zu tun. Von Erklärungen von Witzen zu tun. Also kleinen Goldpärchen, die vielleicht im reissenden Fluss der Geschichte zu finden sind. Mit Ich glaube, ich werde ein Gott bezieht sich Vespasian auf seine Apotheose im Osten des Reiches. Niemand weiss, was eine Apotheose ist, Simon. Dort wurde er nämlich im Zuge des Jüdischen Krieges zum Neuen Serapis. Ach Gott, also zum neuen menschlichen Inkarnation des ägyptischen Gottes Serapis.
Dies wurde zumindest im Osten des Römischen Reiches auch entsprechend zur Herrscherlegitimation genutzt, aber kam in Rom nicht so wahnsinnig gut an. Mit seinem Witz bezieht er sich also wahrscheinlich selbstironisch auf sein eigenes Gottwerden und dass er nach seinem Tod ja auch in Rom als vergöttlichter Divus Vespasianus verehrt werden wird, was tatsächlich auch passiert ist, nach seinem Tod wurde auf Senatsbeschluss zum vergöttlichten Vespasian. Was genau der Witz mit dem Vorzeichen ist, ist mir selbst nicht ganz klar. Über Vespasian gibt es im Gegensatz zu den anderen Kaisern des ersten Jahrhunderts ungewöhnlich viele Vorzeichen und um. Ja, gut. Das ist unsere sehr beliebte Rubrik, Comedy in der Historie. Die Humorlupe, wo selbst die Erklärer sagen, sie wissen nicht genau, was passiert. Aber ist das nicht ein Wortspiel mit Serapis und Pissoir? weil da habe ich jetzt dran gedacht, aber dafür, dass wir, wir als, ich finde wir als Comedy-Podcast, dass wir uns jetzt zumindest vornehmen, meiner Geschichte zu buddeln und zu gucken, wo kommen wir denn eigentlich her? Wo kommen denn die Witze, die wir machen, überhaupt weg? Das finde ich super, dass wir das machen. Wird in Zukunft noch einsteckiger funktionieren, vielleicht. Ist ein Schenkelklopfer, also ich glaube, da müssen wir uns jetzt alle kurz erholen. Nee, diese Rubrik ist wirklich so erfrischend lustig, wo ich wirklich sage, es lohnt sich, da auch mal in die Geschichte zu gehen. Viele fragen sich, warum denn Historiker, warum denn Geschichte, interessiert mich noch nicht, was die Mitleide gemacht haben. Nein, da kommen ein paar gute Gags zustande. Nee, das ist wirklich, also wir haben Rubriken hier, wo Augen nicht trocken bleiben.
Ich sag mal Antenne Alte rein und die Humorlufe, Antenne Afrika und die Humorlufe, das sind Garanten für, ich lache mich kaputt, das reißt mich mit dem Alltag aus und lässt mir Lachen ins Gesicht.
Dafür sind wir hier, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche und macht's gut, wir heben ab.
Ciao!